welcome back to cbs mornings today we're
looking what happens to our clothes when
we no longer want them according to some
reports americans buy about five times
more clothing than they did back in 1980
and one study suggests we wear each item
an average of just listen to this seven
times that increase can be tied to fast
fashion that's what they call it trendy
designs that are mass-produced at a very
long low cost so here's a question where
do all those clothes end up
the u.s leads the world in exporting
used textiles more than one and a half
billion pounds are shipped out of the
country every year deborah paddle
followed some of those donations to west
africa
have you ever wondered where the clothes
you throw away end up some of them
travel thousands of miles to ghana this
is actually no beach paradise look a
little closer and your discarded fast
fashion could be rotting right here
it's the dark skeleton lurking inside
fast fashion's trendy closet
our generous donations are not always as
charitable as they seem in ghana's
kantamanto market
trucks offload these bales stuffed with
our used clothing
it's estimated 15 million items arrive
here every week
is only a country of 30 million people
that's fashion designer and activist
sami oting who knows every inch of this
seven acre maze with its more than five
thousand stalls before they used to have
like good quality clothes but now
there's a lot of trash and a lot of like
very low quality clothes he upcycles
garments from kantamanto but says
increasingly these synthetic fabrics
cannot be salvaged
the whole fast fashion module is built
around like you know building cheap
clothing and the us is the biggest
culprit exporting more second-hand
clothing than any other country on earth
i can't even lift this bag it's so heavy
stuffed with clothes from america
the bales cost traders anywhere between
twenty five to five hundred dollars
untangling them is a tense tussle
as they have no idea what's inside it's
the luck of the draw
trader zaliato asari is barely breaking
even that's a nice one sometimes making
as little as ten dollars after gambling
on garments that have no second life
they're known as
which means dead white man's clothes
dead man quite close why
you'd have to have died to have given
away so many clothes
we found everything from big name brands
to personalized t-shirts like this one
from pennsylvania this t-shirt was
clearly made very recently it references
covert and has already made it thousands
of miles to ghana
ghanaians do a remarkable job with our
castle
tailoring
and even tie dyeing them back to life
but it's not enough to reduce the glut
of clothing created by our addiction to
fast fashion
so if actually kantamanto is
highlighting america's waste price
exactly exactly
exactly waste has been built into the
model of uh fast fashion you know like
overproduced over produce overproduced
and then in the end like people were
closed for just like two weeks and then
just discard them the waste does not end
up in america ultimately it entertaining
in contamination but it doesn't stay in
kantamanto
when the rains come some of this textile
waste washes up on the local beaches
they're called tentacles and they're
everywhere on this beach discarded
rotting tangled mess of clothing they're
buried so deep it's almost impossible to
pull them out
and this is nothing compared to ghana's
overwhelmed landfills where the rest of
the unsold clothing ends up
head of the city's waste management
solomon noy has a message for americans
deal with it do not hide under the guise
of donations of secondhand clothing and
then you ship them over to us just to
cause problems to us
problems like the toxic fumes from old
fatima's dump site where a massive
precipice looms formed not of rock but
indestructible discarded clothing
i mean you can see the brand when you
come here you see a whole lot of brands
you adidas h m
zara
it's estimated that 40 percent of all
the clothing bales end up as landfill
so basically this is where dead white
men's clothes go
in the end yes our good intentions
have created an environmental nightmare
halfway around the world for cbs
morning's debra patter akra ghana
that's oh it's not good i mean it makes
it makes me picture my own closet and
think that is not good makes you second
guess going and buying more clothing
yeah it really does it makes me worried
for the whole planet to be honest with
you i mean that's a big issue and it's
such a big
systemic issue it's hard to fix no doubt
that's something we can all do we can
all help with that we can all do our
part yes we can that's for sure thank
you very much deborah pata